[Music]
well the latest cyber crime is a tech
scam that uses your own phone number to
try to trick you we're helping you to
avoid the text that brings trouble in
tonight's cyber safe parent
some of you might have received a text
message recently from yourself it's just
one more way that these cyber criminals
are are getting crafty on trying to
trick people into clicking on something
spoofing phone numbers is a common trick
to get people to respond cyber criminals
get a block of phone numbers program the
scripted scam and off it goes in mass
and they can do them in bunches hundreds
even thousands at a time customers are
receiving spam messages that look like
they're actually coming from their own
phone numbers more than 5 000 incidents
of the same number spam text messages
were tracked last week many impacting
verizon customers really any company is
vulnerable with these specific scams
when they're sending out the phone
numbers in a lot of cases i don't think
the suspects even know who the carriers
are the messages from your number is
from your alleged wireless carrier
references your wireless bill and a link
to a free gift the link leads to
malicious websites they're constantly
looking for any avenue that they can to
be able to get you know access to
people's networks or systems or their
personal identifying information
americans received a total of 87 billion
spam text messages in 2021 a 58 percent
increase from the previous year these
sms phishing attacks are always trying
to get you to click on a link lieutenant
alan larson warns that is the moment you
become compromised the biggest danger
with that is if you're clicking on the
link generally speaking they're either
taking you to you know a fake network
server or website so if you get a text
from you don't click on the link
screenshot it if you plan to report it
but make sure you delete it and if a
friend texts you a link before clicking
call them first make sure they weren't
hacked the biggest thing is just take
whatever measures you can to protect
yourself
now if you dealt with this tech scam or
any type of attempted cyber crime you
can file a complaint at the internet
crime complaint center at
ic3.gov ic3.gov